Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Uccak, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig
und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Doktor.
Danke, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Ich werde Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen, bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Martin Steinbach.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachname langsam buchstabieren?
S-T-E-I-N-B-A-C-K
Ok, Herr Steinbach, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
4.06.1957
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 78 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 Meter.
Wie ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Schmidt.
Ok, danke für die Informationen.
Herr Steinbach, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zurzeit?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen in beiden Waden.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit ungefähr zwei bis drei Tagen habe ich starke Schmerzen.
Aber seit ungefähr fünf Wochen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Sind diese Schmerzen im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden?
Ja, immer schlimmer geworden.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Plötzlich aufgetreten, aber in Verlauf der Zeit sind die Schmerzen immer schlimmer geworden.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher drückend oder stechend, brennend?
Dumpf, Doktor.
Schreiben diese Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe immer bei den Waden bemerkt.
Ok.
Herr Steinbach, haben Sie eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen bemerkt?
Ich meine Bewegung oder Drucken?
Ja, Doktor.
Ich habe bemerkt, dass es besser wird, wenn ich die Beine hochlege.
Ok.
Herr Steinbach, haben Sie an den Waden Hautfarbeveränderung bemerkt?
Ich meine Rötung oder Blässehaut?
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, Doktor.
Die Haut an meinen Beinen sieht verändert aus.
Sie sind kälter als sonst Blässe und sie wirken irgendwie dünner.
Ok.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr
leichten und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde sie auf einer Schkala von 6 oder 9 bemerken.
Neun?
Nein, fast nicht.
8 oder 9.
8 bis 9.
Herr Steinbach, soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmitte geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen
noch ein bisschen bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Doktor, ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen.
Es wäre besser, Sie mir eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Also darf ich fragen, haben Sie eine Allergie gegen Schmerzmittel?
Ja, ich bin gegen Penisinalergie, Doktor.
Und leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Nierenversagen?
Ja, nein, ich habe nicht Nierenkrankheit, nein.
Alles klar.
Schwester Müller, bitte geben Sie den Patienten eine Schmerzmittel.
Ok.
Herr Steinbach, wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt besser oder?
Ich fühle mich sehr gut.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Ok, das freut mich.
Ok.
Herr Steinbach, können Sie einfach laufen, ohne diese Schmerzen zu bekommen?
Ja, wenn ich bei Bebegünnen laufen, ist die Schmerzen schlechter.
Wie weit können Sie laufen?
Ich meine, wie viele Meter?
Ungefähr 200 Meter oder 300 Meter.
Ok.
Träten diese Schmerzen auch in Ruhe auf?
Ich habe nicht bemüht, nein.
Ok.
Leiden Sie unter Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribben?
Ich habe nicht bemüht.
Alles klar.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Ich habe keine Husten und Luftnot, nein.
Oder leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Brustschmerzen?
Ich habe nicht bemüht, Doktor.
Das freut mich.
Alles klar.
Herr Steinbach, haben Sie in diesem Bereich, ich meine Wadenbereich, Haarausfall bemerkt?
Oder Nagelveränderungen?
Doktor, ich habe bemerkt, ich habe Haarausfall, ja.
Aber Nagelveränderungen habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Alles klar.
Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Übel, brechen, ja.
Mir ist oft übel, ja.
Und mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ich habe keine erbrechen, aber mir ist oft übel, ja.
Ok, verstanden.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttefrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, aber seit drei Tagen habe ich keinen Apathit, Doktor.
Und ich habe Verstopfung.
Seit wann haben Sie Verstopfung?
Seit einem Woche, ja.
Ok.
Haben Sie in der letzter Zeit ab- oder zugenommen, ich meine unwillkürlich?
Ja, nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ich bin immer gleichgewicht.
Ok, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen? Nein, keine.
Ok, schlafen Sie gut?
Wegen Übel und Verstopfung.
Manchmal habe ich Bauchschmerzen wegen Verstopfung.
Und schlafe ich nicht gut.
Ich habe Durchschlafstörungen.
Ok, alles klar.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein oder?
Was gegen?
Gegen diese Schlafstörungen, ich meine.
Ich habe ein Schlafmittel im Däme gekauft.
Aber er nähert mich nicht jetzt, wie es heißt.
Ich nehme es bei Bedarf ein.
Ok, alles klar.
Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor.
Ok, und haben Sie in der letzter Zeit eine lange Reise gemacht?
Mit dem Auto oder im Flugzeug?
Was bedeutet in letzter Zeit?
Ich meine in ein paar Wochen?
Ein paar Wochen, nein.
Ich habe keine Urlaub oder andere Reise gemacht, nein.
Alles klar.
Ok.
Herr Steinbach, darf ich fragen,
haben Sie ein Medikament gegen diese Schmerzen?
Waren Sie schon beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ja Doktor, ich habe zwei Schmerzmittel angeboten bekommen.
Aber ich habe abgelenkt, weil ich schon dreimal 600 mg Überprofen genommen habe.
Das hat aber nicht gebracht.
Ok.
Und waren Sie ein anderer Arzt gewesen?
Ich meine wegen dieser Beschwerden?
Ich gehe nicht an den anderen Arzt, nein.
Alles klar.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja Doktor, ich habe seit 20 Jahren chronische Lungenkrankheit.
Chronische Obstruktur Lungenkrankheit, ja.
Ok.
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ja, ich benutze eine Spray, aber ich weiß gerade nicht, wie sie heißt.
Ok, kein Problem.
Also ich werde Ihrem Arzt kontaktieren, ja?
Ok, danke schön.
Ja, gerne.
Und sonst?
Ja, außerdem der Arzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich eine chronische Laryngitis habe.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Nein, ich benutze keine Medikamente.
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein Doktor.
Ok, seit wann leiden Sie an Laryngitis?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Alles klar.
Das war es, oder?
Noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, das war es.
Ok, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden?
Nein, ich hatte keine Operation.
Ok, das freut mich.
Also hatten Sie früher einen Unfall gehabt?
Unfall? Nein.
Ok.
Herr Steinbach, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten noch irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Außer Spray?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Andere.
Eine Medikamente ein Doktor.
Alles klar.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Allergie gegen Penicillin haben.
Ja.
Auslässt sich diese Allergie?
Ja, ich habe Katzenharrallergie.
Bei Kontakt mit Katzen bekomme ich Rückreis und rote Hautstelle.
Ok. Und mit dem Penicillin?
Ja.
Wie auslässt Sie diese Allergie?
Rückreis und Atemnot.
Ok.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unfertigkeiten?
Nein.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Steinbach?
Ja, ich rauche seit 50 Jahren, Doktor.
Und wie viel rauchen Sie?
Ungefähr 40 Zigaretten am Tag.
Ok. Also Herr Steinbach, Sie wissen ja, das Rauchen ist schädlich für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ja.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören oder mindestens das Rauchen zu reduzieren.
Also wir haben ein gutes Programm im Krankenhaus.
Wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen.
Ja, wenn Sie mir helfen können, würde ich sehr glücklich, Doktor.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Ok.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke auch jeden Tag zwei Gläser Schnaps.
Ok. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen, Doktor.
Ok, das freut mich.
Herr Steinbach, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall oder Bluthochdruck?
Ja, mein Vater hat viele chronische Erkrankungen.
Diabetes, Bluthochdruck, eine Schultrüsenüberfunktion und mehrere Herzinfarkte.
Er hat einen Bypass bekommen und lebt jetzt in Altenheim.
Meine Mutter ist schon gestorben. Sie hatte Diabetes und Gewa-Mutterkrebs.
Mein Beileid, Herr Steinbach.
Ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe keine. Ich bin ein Geschwister.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschwistert.
Wohnen Sie alleine?
Ich lebe mit meinem Hund.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Kinder, aber sie sind Erwachsene.
Sind Sie Rentner?
Ja, ich bin Rentner. Früher habe ich im Büro gearbeitet.
Im Büro?
Ja, im Büro.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Steinbach, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor. Was habe ich?
Herr Steinbach, es ist zu früh etwas genau zu sagen, aber ich vermute, dass Sie eine Duschblutstörung in den Beinen haben.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen.
Was machen Sie mit Blut abnehmen?
Herr Steinbach, ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen und besonders Entzündungsparameter.
Und die Parameter über die Duschblut...
Ich habe einen Entzündungsparameter.
Ja, kann sein. Wie gesagt, das ist nur eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Ich möchte nur sichergehen, was Sie haben und was die Ursachen für diese Beschwerden sind.
Deswegen möchte ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen. Das ist sehr wichtig.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob ich in Krankenhaus bleibe oder nach Hause gehen kann.
Ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können und eine Therapie einlassen können.
Dauert es sehr lange?
Also Herr Steinbach...
Wissen Sie, ich habe einen Hund und Sie alleine in meinem Haus.
Okay, ich verstehe. Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Bestimmt können wir eine Lösung dafür finden.
Wir haben hier einen Sozialdienst und können Sie dabei unterstützen.
Okay.
Wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Ich muss jemanden finden, der um meinen Hund kümmert.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, wir können Sie dabei unterstützen. Massen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Danke schön, Doktor. Ich freue mich auf Sie. Danke.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Herr Martin Steinbach ist 68 Jahre alt, 78 Kilogramm schwer und 1,76 Meter groß.
Herr Steinbach stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei bis drei Tagen bestehender, plötzlich aufgetretener, beidseitiger Wadenschmerzen vor.
Der Patienten zufolge seien diese Schmerzen vor fünf Wochen aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen dumpf seien und die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo ausstrahlen.
Außerdem berichtete der Patient über kalte, bläste und dünne Haut am Wadenbereich.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde 8 bis 9 von 10 bewertet und dreimalige 600 Milligramm Ibuprofen hat keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen sich beim Hochlagerung verbessern und beim Bewegung verschlimmern.
Außerdem erwähnte der Patient, dass er etwa 300 Meter Gehstrecken ohne Schmerzen hatte.
Die Fragen nach Schmerzen in Ruhe, Parastese, Hypestese, Dyspnoe, Tussis, Angina Pectoris und Tachikadi wurden verneint.
Der Patient hatte auch Allopathy am Wadenregion.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgen bekannt.
Nausea ohne Emesis, Inapetänz seit 3 Tagen, Obsipation seit einer Woche und Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft und Reiseanamnese wurde verneint.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit 20 Jahren bestehende COPD und seit 2 Jahren bestehende chronische Laryngitis.
Der Patient nahm ein schlaffes Mittel, das er von DM gekauft hatte.
Der Patient hatte Allergie gegen Penicillin, die sich durch Puri-Tuss und Dyspnoe äußert.
Er rauchte 2 Schachteln Zigaretten täglich seit 50 Jahren.
Das entspricht 100 Fakunkirs und er trinke 2 Gläser Schnaps täglich.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass die Mutter an Uteruskarzinom verstorben sei und davor habe sie an Diabetes mellitus gelitten.
Der Vater leide an Diabetes mellitus, arterieller Hypertonie, Hyperthyriose und mehrere Herzinfarkte.
Die Mutter sei an Uteruskarzinom verstorben und davor hat sie an Diabetes mellitus gelitten.
Er sei Einzelkind, geschieden, wohne mit seinem Hund und habe ein gesundes Kind.
Er sei Rentner und arbeitet im Büro.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine PVUK aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet von einem Pervolk.
Der Patient leidet unter bilateralen Wadenschmerzen, kalte, blasse und dünne Haut am Waden und Schmerzen beim Laufen.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine PVUK.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen TvT, Discus prolapsus, Discus prolaps in Betracht, Erisbell in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei dem Pervolk, der Pervolk,
um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei dem Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob die peripheralen Pulse tastbar sind und auch Hautfarbeveränderungen,
offene Wunde, Allophezie, Nägelveränderungen, Ödeme, Eritheme vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose sich zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Leukocytinzal, CAP, BSG, Gerömmungsparameter, Dedumere, Leberwerte, Nierumerte, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Doplex-Sonographie durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Und sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und würde ich einen venösen Zugang legen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten Analgetika verabreichen.
Zusätzlich würde ich ein gefäßt-chirurgisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Bei diesen Patienten würde ich eine Thromboliser-Therapie anordnen.
Oder wir können auch eine Thromboktomie während einer Angiografie...
Herr Kollegen, Thromboktomie ist eine Behandlungsmethode für die TFT.
Ach so, ok. Sie haben recht, Herr Oberarzt.
Und wenn Sie mit dieser Vergehungsweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Kollegen, wie können Sie bei körperlicher Untersuchung P?A?V?K diagnostizieren?
Zuerst würde ich die Peripheralpulse abtasten. Das ist sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten.
Ich würde auch die Hautveränderungen beobachten, ob eine Allopäzie oder Nagelveränderungen oder offene Wunde oder Hautdünnung vorhanden sind.
Und es gibt auch eine Methode, also wir gleichen den Blutdruck zwischen Oberarm und Unterchenkel.
Ja, genau.
Zwischen Oberarm und...
Was heisst diese Methode?
Der Name der Methode habe ich leider vergessen, Herr Oberarzt.
Ankel Braschendegs?
Ok, ja, Sie haben recht.
Herr Kollegen, was machen Sie nach der Dublixonographie positive Diagnose stellen? Welche andere Diagnose führen Sie durch?
Ja, wir können bei den Patienten eine Angiographie durchführen.
Welche Angiographie?
Wie viele Angiographien kennen Sie?
Ja, also CT-Angiographie, MOT-Angiographie kenne ich und digitale Substantialangiographie.
Genau.
Welche positiven Ergebnisse hat digitale Substantialangiographie?
Welche Vorteile hat?
Welche Vorteile?
Also wir können die Gefäße genau beurteilen, ob es eine Verengkung bei der Gefäße gibt.
Können wir gleichzeitig eine Therapie durchführen?
Wenn die Behandlung nicht möglich ist, welche Therapie empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Wir können eine Trombolise, nein nicht eine Trombolise, wir können, ich habe nur Grundkenntnisse mit diesem Thema, Herr Oberarzt.
Bypass?
Ach ja, Sie haben recht.
Ja, Bypass-Operation empfehlen Sie den Patienten.
Nach der Therapie, was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Ja, also Nikotinkarenz ist sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten und Lebensstillveränderungen sind auch sehr wichtig.
Ja, sehr wichtig, ich empfehle den Patienten Gewichtsabnahme, Nikotinkarenz und Gehschulung.
Ja, also der Patient hat keine Erkrankungen wie Diabetes, Melutes oder Hypercholesterolemie.
Ok, in diesem Fall möchten Sie ein EKG schreiben und Eschokardiographie durchführen?
Der Patient leidet unter keinem Herzproblem, aber ja, wir können eine EKG schreiben und auch eine Eschokardiographie durchführen,
weil wir können eine Klappe, Störungen feststellen, das ist ein Risikofaktor für eine Emboli und diese Situation kann eine PVK, akutes PVK verursachen.
Deswegen können wir diese Untersuchungen durchführen.
Welches Stadium hat der Patient?
Ja, der Patient hat Stadium 2a, also er kann über 300 Meter laufen ohne Schmerzen zu bekommen, also die Gehstrecke ist 300 Meter, das bedeutet Stadium 2a.
Welche anderen Krankheiten verursacht PVK?
Welche anderen Krankheiten?
Also wie gesagt, die Herzprobleme wie zum Beispiel Atrialfibulation verursachen eine Emboli und das kann eine akute PVK verursachen, ich glaube, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Und?
Atmosphäre?
Ja.
In der Gefäße?
Ja, Atmosphäre, genau.
Und Rhino-Phänomen?
Rhino-Phänomen, ja.
Okay, Sie haben recht.
Wenn der Patient bei der Körperlosen-Unterzuchtung bei Hochlagerung starke Schmerzen hat, welche Krankheiten denken Sie?
Bei der Hochlagerung, also das ist PVK, also Hochlagerung verursacht verstärkte Schmerzen beim PVK und das verursacht eine verlinnte Schmerzen beim TVT.
Wie können wir bei der Körperlosen-Unterzuchtung TVT ausschließen?
Welche Zeichen überprüfen Sie?
Bei der TVT können wir Oedäme, Erytheme, Blausucht feststellen und es gibt auch...
Gibt es vier Zeichen?
Vier Zeichen.
Hab ich schon vergessen.
Heier Zeichen.
Meier Zeichen.
Und Druckschmerzen auch.
Und gibt es Lassek Zeichen?
Lassek Zeichen.
Bei Hochlagerung hat er starke Schmerzen, PVK positiv.
Das bedeutet, manche Autoren sagen Lassek Zeichen positiv.
Welche Peripheren Arterie überprüfen Sie während der Körperlosen-Unterzuchtung?
Arterie Dorsalepidis und Arterie Tibialis Posterior würde ich besonders abtasten.
Aber wir können auch Arterie Poplitea Posterior oder Arterie Femeralis auch abtasten.
Arterie Tibialis Posterior und Arterie Dorsalis Posterior.
Welchen Unterschied hat TVT und PVK?
Ja, also bei der körperlichen Unterzuchtung oder Herr Warst?
Was ist der Unterschied?
Okay, also bei der TVT beobachten wir Erythme, Ödeme.
Aber bei der PVK beobachten wir Blässe, Kalte und Dünne Haut.
Und bei der TVT auch Überwärme Haut.
Also Erythme, Ödem und Überwärmung.
Ja, und bei der PVK abtasten wir die Pulse und es gibt Probleme.
Bei abtasten die Pulse und es gibt kein Problem bei TVT mit der Pulse.
Und die typischen Zeichen, Meier, Hohmann, Lassekzeichen, haben wir bei TVT und Ankel.
Branchindex in PVK und eine Reise, lange Reise anamnese bei TVT und keine Reise anamnese bei der PVK.
Ja, und auch bei der Duplexonographie oder Angeographie, es gibt eine Thrombose bei TVT und eine Verengung, Arterioschleurose bei PVK.
Ist es möglich in diesem Fall Diabetik für Neuropathie?
Also es gibt keine Taparstgefühle, keine Parastese, keine Hypestese, es gibt keine Diabetesgeschichte in der Anamnese.
Aber der Vater leidet an Diabetes mellitus.
Oder Mutter?
Ja, genau, Mutter, auch Mutter. Also wir sollen Blutzucker auch bestimmen lassen.
Okay, Herr Kollegen, Sie gehen in unser Infodisk und nehmen Ihre Certificate. Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg in Ihrem Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank Herr Oberhaus, Sie sind sehr nett. Das war eine sehr lange Prüfung bei mir, wissen Sie.
Also das bedeutet, dass ich glaube, es hat etwa 30 Minuten gedauert.
Vielen Dank.